إيلينا تهانينا لأنك صنعت
التاريخ هنا اليوم
لكازاخستان ، لكن كانت مباراة
صعبة ومعركة قاسية بالنسبة لك في أي نقطة
خلال المباراة بدأت
تصدق أنه يمكنك الفوز وماذا
قلت لنفسك لتحقيق ذلك
كنت متوترة للغاية قبل المباراة
منذ البداية أعتقد أنني أستطيع
الفوز لأنه بدون هذه الأشياء للذهاب
والمنافسة لذلك اعتقدت منذ البداية
لكنني شعرت أن أعصابي
لا تسمح لي بعرض أفضل ما لدي
لم أستطع أن أخدم ذلك جيدًا مثل
المباريات السابقة ، لذا بعد خسارة
المجموعة الأولى كنت أحاول فقط أن أقول
لنفسي إنها مجرد نهائية ،
لقد فعلت بالفعل كل شيء
ممكن ، إنه سجل بالفعل إذا كان بإمكانك
الفوز بها ، فهذا أمر رائع إن لم تكن كذلك  لدي
الكثير من الوقت للمحاولة والقيام بذلك مرة أخرى ، كما
تعلم ، لذلك في الثانية والثالثة كنت
أركز فقط على كل نقطة في لعبتي حول
كيفية العثور على الأمواج وكل هذه
الأشياء ، وبعد ذلك
عندما أنهيت المباراة  منزعج ولأنني كنت
في المباراة يمكنك رؤية ردة فعلي
لم أصدق ما حدث